[Musik]
das alleinsein die einsamkeit dieser
jungen frau dieser alleinerziehenden
mutter in einer vereins heiligen
umgebung ist im wesentlichen die
geschichte die der junge österreichische
regisseur lukas feigen feld in dem film
ein ganzes jahrzehnt
niemals
dazu sei ein film der in einer zeit
spielt die nicht genau definiert ist
aber man kann relativ deutlicher
annehmen dass wir es mit dem späten
mittelalter zu tun haben
das abseitige leben von albbruck erweckt
den alltag von der leute die es mit ihr
zu tun bekommen
manche glauben vielleicht das wird auch
nicht ganz deutlich das album eine hexe
sein könnte
für uns gewissermaßen wir eine
gesellschaft in der man eben noch sehr
stark die ja die rhythmen der natur als
furchterregende punkten hat und in der
iss die ganze zeit eben darum ging dass
man sich gegenüber der natur nicht zu
helfen wusste in die aber eben auch
diese natur eine sehr faszinierende
qualität hat und diese faszinierende
qualität zeigt haben ganz großartige
immer wieder auch unheimliche weise
eine sowohl visuelle akustische
erfahrung der außergewöhnlichen art ganz
anders als das was man normalerweise so
im jungen deutschen mainstream
kennenlernt hergatz ist ein film der ein
bisschen mit den konventionen des
horrorfilms spielt aber nicht im
strengen sinn ein horloff in ist sondern
ein film der sich sehr stark dafür
interessiert welche macht bilder haben
und viele der bilder mit denen freie
feld spielt haben tatsächlich die
qualität der sie unser unbewusstes sehr
stark beschäftigen
der zug sei es nicht für ein großes
publikum gedacht aber für menschen die
das kino in seiner ganzen bandbreite der
möglichkeit kennenlernen wollen oder die
auch mal etwas wagen wollen für die saga
zu
der film der woche auf jeden fall